say drawer again drawer say it again
drawer keep going draw draw draw draw
draw draw draw draw draw water water
water
[Music]
today we're gonna listen to some
American accents and decide which one of
them is the sexiest there might be some
sarcasm I am partial to a southern
accent whether that be Texas Southern
Atlanta southern I find a grip of it
sexy cuz like I don't know what it is I
can't even say it right but the way of
man in Atlanta speaks whoo I tell you I
don't have a specific hankering for an
American accent because I think they're
all kind of gross I'm really just
excited about being serenaded in my own
language let's start there
mr. Alabama sonnet 43 how do I love thee
let me count the ways I love thee to the
depth and breadth and height most quiet
need by Sun and candlelight
I love these freely as men strive all
right I love thee purely as they as they
turn from praise and if God choose I
shall love thee better after death Wow
mm-hmm giddyup
I was shook when I first heard his voice
I was like Lord panties police bang on
you know what I've never heard a poem
read in a southern accent that was a new
experience
youie the Texas a Tennessee no Alabama
hola oh we all sound the same no Blackie
hear it now loud and clear voice sounds
great thank you um definitely southern
sultry I guess hey I feel the heat
coming from the South perfect
on points and worth it
yes I'll take you to mr. New York time
to get serenaded by to Celia ben jonson
1616 great can't wait
drink to me only with thine eyes or
leave a kiss but in the cup and I'll not
look for why it could not be with it I
love you I love you too can I guess what
I know where this is for oh ok
I wouldn't want this accent to read me a
poem but I'd love you to say dirty
things to me all of it are you from
Boston I have an apple you never bought
that where are you why I'm so bad at
this
where are you from where are you from
what do you sound like say it say it's
something again I give you so you want a
key word sure water draw oh are you from
New York yeah I'm from New York
I'm so sorry father yes you don't have
the thickest that I think but I hear it
I hear I've moved I've moved around a
lot since then but it's a you know you
could take the boy out of New York but
never the New York out of the boy mr.
Pittsburgh welcome oh hello thanks for
the pedals well I just thought they were
as beautiful as you are
wow she walks in beauty like the night
on cloudless climes and starry skies
what kind of what cloudless cloudless of
cloudless climes and starry skies and
all that's best of dark and bright a
mind at peace with all pillow a heart
whose love is innocent
mmm is what innocent yesterday like you
my dear has done
hmm you could be from like three
different places
I'm only from one place that is what
happens that's how that happened
okay I literally have no idea where this
accidents from just America read the
first two lines again William please she
walks in beauty like the night of
cloudless climes and starry skies say
starry again starry say it again
starry starry are you from Philly oh man
what an insult other side of the state
about 300 miles down the Turnpike Oh are
you from Pittsburgh yes oh my god nobody
yeah you got dad's from time from family
my dad's from Pittsburgh mr. Boston hey
baby girl
oh hello very you how's it going oh yeah
well I'm going to be reading a nice
little poem for ya Bo's I hope you're
ready hey baby girl oh my goodness
have you already got a little gift for
you oh I'm gonna give you right oh yeah
you got Michael Paula Dean I already
know where you're from so I'm gonna read
a really nice poem for ya
okay it's called a red red rose by
Robert Burns and it will Robert Robert
Burns my love is like the melody that's
so sweetly played in tune as fare I
thought my bonny lass she's loving this
poem thank God for Robert Burns for
helping me address and I will come again
my love for a thousand yeah you amen
well we doesn't get yes we're going to
Vegas
you're definitely from Boston absolutely
are you sure yeah I'm gonna get this one
right you're from Boston you're right
I knew it cuz you know my woolmarket my
seed there you go got the mahkumat going
on she gets it when she found love is
love right it's you understand me
come on but I could've done my Mark
Wahlberg impression if you wouldn't do
it now my love is like a red rose wow
that's really new my accent might not be
the sexiest but if you put the mock
Wahlberg little tone into it but yeah
ladies love it alright where's my car
but if Mark Wahlberg said hey where's my
car I don't know help me find it
honestly I have to say it's a tie
between Pittsburgh and Boston whoo
because Pittsburgh for obvious reasons
Boston I have lived in Boston for a
little bit also I just kind of like the
accent I think when push comes to shove
but everyone else's voice was great I
don't mean to put you down you all have
lovely voices and this has been the best
day of my life
[Music]
Boston Boston Pittsburgh Pittsburgh New
York Alabama Alabama hey um you guys are
all in my bed and I'm not complaining
about it
Wow oh you've gentlemen you look quite
lovely and I want every last one
apparently I can only choose one so I'm
gonna have to go with mr. Alabama
because whoo child
we started strong and he gave me a rose
we're the rest of y'all at what's going
on Oh
militias what hello hello okay we got
Boston yeah New York New York Tokyo burg
[Music]